c'est la première fois qu'on arrive avec
un texte qui en plus de ça a été adopté
je vous faisais la liste des articles du
Règlement jusqu'au vote bloqué qui est
le plus grave donc avec un bon un
passage en force qui a été fait sur
cette question ça changerait quoi ça
change rien
mais exactement
Adrien cloué moi-même nous la fuite la
commission pour que vous puissiez la
suivre nous sortirons régulièrement et
vous nous rappeler oui mais en fait
comprenez que quand le débat pourquoi
est-ce que le débat est publique à
l'Assemblée nationale ou au Sénat par
ailleurs c'est parce que chacun et
chacune peut alors suivre les débats et
donc je trouve intéressant dans un
moment où ce texte n'a pas été discuté
dans beaucoup des aspects je trouve
intéressant que les citoyens alors la
suite de la commission mixte paritaire
et bien c'est le texte qui devrait en
sortir jeudi avec le vote au Sénat à
l'Assemblée pour l'instant le
gouvernement affirme vouloir éviter le
recours à l'article 49-3 à l'Assemblée
nationale est-ce que vous y croyez
s'ils n'ont pas de majorité ils
utiliseront 49.3 et s'il n'avait pas
voulu utiliser le 49-3 alors ils
auraient choisi un projet de loi
classique qui nous aurait donné le temps
d'étudier vous y attendez une réforme
qui va changer la vie d'ailleurs des
générations futures donc je ne suis pas
naïve sur cette question là s'ils n'ont
pas la majorité ils utiliseront 49-3 ce
qui pour le coup sera quand même une
preuve de faiblesse de ce pouvoir
extrêmement forte parce que de nouveau
on aura un passage en force mais vous
pensez que à trouver sa majorité ou pas
j'en sais autant que vous moi j'entends
des LR qui disent que ils voteront
contre la réforme notamment parce qu'il
l'a trouvé le gouvernement en train
d'essayer de chercher des voies à
l'Assemblée les réunions à Matignon se
multiplient avec celles et ceux qui
siégeront à la CMP de la part de la
majorité donc je vois bien que les
tractations vont bon train et qu'ils
espèrent on arrivera
avec les élus de la CMP LR sont à
Matignon
j'ai dit la majorité vous voulez la
suppression du 49 3 vous avez des
collègues écologistes qui le réclament
c'est dans notre programme présidentiel
effectivement et donc vous allez vous
joindre à ceux qui le réclame à travers
une composition de loi
[Musique]